Where were we last time?
Last time we had discovered
that radiation,
and we're going back to Lecture
4 notes, because I think I have
a little bit left on Lecture 4
notes, we discovered that
radiation also behaves like a
particle.
And it behaves like a particle,
as exhibited in this
photoelectric effect.
That is, in order to get an
electron out,
what we needed to do was to put
in a particle of energy.
We needed to put in a packet of
energy.
We needed to put in a quantum
of energy.
And as long as that quantum of
energy, that packet of energy,
that particle of energy was
larger than the work function,
we would get one electron out
for every packet we put in.
That's an example of the
particle-like nature to
radiation, this photoelectric
effect.
But Einstein also went on to
show an even more convincing
property of the particle-like
nature of radiation,
or a photon.
And that is he showed that a
photon has momentum,
even though a photon does not
have mass, or essentially no
rest mass.
And, of course,
momentum is a very
particle-like property.
p, for momentum,
is equal to the mass times
velocity.
If a particle,
if a photon,
if radiation has momentum,
then it's acting very much like
a particle.
How did he do this?
Well, Einstein took the
relativistic equations of
motion, which he himself wrote
down.
And what he showed from that is
that a photon had momentum p
here.
And the momentum of the photon
is defined by the frequency of
the radiation.
That is, that momentum was
given by h, again Planck's
constant there,
that quantization constant,
times the frequency over the
speed of light.
And since, of course,
we know the relationship
between the frequency and the
wavelength, we can write the
momentum of a photon as h over
lambda.
So, if you have radiation of
some wavelength lambda,
that radiation,
those photons,
have this momentum h over
lambda, this photon momentum,
even though photons don't have
mass.
And the actual demonstration of
this experimentally took a few
more years.
And it was demonstrated first
in something called the Compton
Effect, which was the
interaction of an X-ray photon
with some matter.
And you could see it,
transfer momentum.
And I've got to show you here
this website from the University
of Colorado again.
And this is just a video of a
photon gun, here,
shooting photons.
And here is this enemy atom
coming at you.
And you're shooting these
photons.
And, sure enough,
you can repel that atom and
make it go the other direction
because of the momentum of the
photon.
But of course,
if you lower the power and
you're not really good with your
fingers here,
you can get clobbered.
Here now I am going to try this
again.
This is almost too easy.
Now I lower the power so that
the rate of the photons are much
slower, and I am going to be
able to turn this guy around.
No problem.
There we go.
Repelled it right off.
So it really is the case that--
Let me see if I can get this guy
here, I got clobbered.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, you'll be better at that
game than I am.
It is just that phenomena.
What I am showing you here that
led to the experimental feat of
atom trapping,
trapping an atom in space.
How do they do that?
Well, what they did is they
took some unsuspecting atom and
they came in with some photons,
a laser beam,
a high power laser beam
directed in this way.
And, of course,
that pushed this atom down.
But now, if you come in with
the laser beam in that
direction, all the photon
momentum is going to push the
atom up so now you have
constrained it in this
dimension.
And you send another laser beam
this way and another one this
way, and now you've constrained
it in this dimension.
And then you send the laser
beam in this way and a laser
beam in that way and constrained
it in the third dimension.
You've trapped an atom in space
via photon momentum.
And this is what Steve Chu and
Stanford and Bill Phillips at
NIST did in the middle 1990s and
received a Nobel Prize for,
this atom trapping,
here, in 1977.
No, 1997.
Sorry.
Photons have momentum.
And the reason this is so
important, the reason this
experiment was also so important
is because it is the first step
in producing a Bose-Einstein
condensate.
A Bose-Einstein condensate is
where you take an atom,
which is a boson,
actually, and you cool it down
to such low temperatures that
these atoms condense.
So, you've got to cool it down
very much so.
You have to get to the micro
Kelvin range.
And the first step in cooling
an atom down is this atom
trapping, this laser atom
trapping.
This will get you down to
Kelvin or a little bit lower or
so.
And, of course,
what I mean by lowering the
temperature is that I've slowed
this atom down.
The temperature of the gas
related to how fast this atom is
moving.
If I slow it down,
I am cooling the gas.
This here is that first step in
getting the atom to condense.
It's the first step in cooling
the gas down.
Then there are many other
steps.
And, actually,
the boson condensate,
one of the individuals who
accomplished that feat is right
here in the Physics Department.
One of my colleagues,
Wolfgang Ketterle.
Many of you will get to meet
In fact, he might even be
teaching a section of 8.01.
Is that right?
Pardon.
Recitation, okay.
Great.
Maybe he will tell you some
more about it,
if he hasn't already.
So, photons have momentum.
Now, what have we seen?
Well, what we have seen is that
radiation exhibits both the
wave-like behavior and this
particle-like behavior.
And, just in general,
experiments where the radiation
produces a change in matter,
like the photoelectric effect,
that's a change in matter,
right?
An electron gets ripped off of
the material.
Experiments in which a change
in the matter is effected.
In that case,
usually the radiation exhibits
particle-like behavior,
experiments in which the
radiation interaction results in
a change in the spatial
distribution of the radiation.
Well, in that case then
radiation exhibits its wave-like
behavior.
And so it's not really a proper
question or an appropriate
question to ask whether light is
a particle or is it a wave.
The appropriate question is to
ask whether light behaves like a
particle or behaves like a wave,
depending on the particular
experimental conditions.
Now, this kind of wave-particle
duality, or the ability of it to
behave like a wave or a particle
is not a contradiction.
It's just the fundamental
nature of light.
It might seem like a
contradiction to you because
your everyday experience doesn't
allow you to see that both
properties can be there.
Your everyday experience says
it's a particle or it's a wave,
but this is a part of nature,
of our world that you don't
have the experience with every
single day so it seems strange.
But it is the way light works.
It's like someone asked me,
what is the form of a photon?
And when you ask that question
that's fine, but you have to
realize what you want for an
answer is to draw an analogy
between that photon in something
that you can experience
everyday.
And the bottom line is you
cannot draw that analogy
correctly because that photon is
not something that you can
relate correctly to your
everyday experience.
It's a different part of
nature.
It's just one that you don't
see every day,
so it seems strange.
You have to be willing to
accept kind of new rules,
new phenomena that are just
outside of your everyday
experience.
They're out there.
As you delve into nature more
deeply, you will see that.
Okay, so we've taken care of
radiation, the wave-particle
duality of light and matter.
Now what we've got to do is
we've got to talk about matter,
and we've got to talk about its
wave-like properties and also
its particle-like properties.
Well, its particle-like
properties are certainly
something that is within your
everyday experience.
You can understand matter as a
particle.
What's more difficult to
understand is matter behaving
like a wave.
For example,
if you had a situation where
you have the surface of a nickel
crystal.
And what I am showing you right
here are two nickel atoms,
just two nickel atoms of this
surface here.
And the two nickel atoms are
spaced about 2x10^-10 meters
from each other,
given the lattice spacing of a
nickel crystal.
And now if I went and I sent
electrons into this nickel
surface, again,
I'm just showing you two of the
atoms.
If I came in with electrons,
electrons are particles because
J.
Thompson showed us that.
Eventually the mass of those
electrons was determined.
But what you might expect is
that those electrons would come
in and then backscatter from the
surface atoms and do so in all
directions so that out here,
where we have a phosphor
screen, and now that screen
happens to be curved just so it
will be easier for us to talk
about the geometry of this
problem here,
you might expect naively that
these electrons scatter in all
directions.
And everywhere where they hit
the screen, the screen lights
up.
Well, this is just the
experiment that Davidson and
Germer did in 1927,
along with G.
Thompson, George Thompson,
so the son of J.
J.
Thompson.
Actually, G.
Thompson did the experiment in
a little different way than
Davidson and Germer.
And I am going to explain the
Davidson and Germer experiment
here.
And now what I've done is I've
taken my nickel atoms and just
made them smaller,
and I did so because I need to
clean up this diagram a little
bit for the geometry that we're
going to do, but I have left the
lattice spacing accurate here.
And what Davidson and Germer
did was to bring in an electron
beam at 54 electron volts.
And they looked to see how
these electrons scattered back
from that surface onto that
screen.
And lo and behold,
what they found was that those
electrons did not scatter
isotropically.
They did not go in all
directions, but there seemed to
be a preferred scattering angle
here.
And one of those scattering
angles right here is 50.7
degrees.
This angle right in here,
that's the angle from the
surface normal to the direction
in which this electron scatters.
They observed some scattered
intensity, lots of electron flux
at this angle here,
about 50.7 degrees.
And they observed a lot of
intensity right at the normal
angle, right here.
So, the electron comes in and
scatters right back.
And, depending on the
experimental conditions,
they observed some intensity at
a very large scattering angle
here.
What does this look like?
It looks like interference
phenomena, right?
It looks like the results of
the two-slit experiment that we
did.
There is a very bright spot,
a very intense spot right in
the center.
Then there is a dark spot.
Then there is a very intense
spot.
Then there is a dark spot.
Then another intense spot.
It looks like interference
phenomena.
Well, let's see if we can
understand that interference
phenomena.
Here is that same diagram.
I just cleaned it up a little
bit.
What we're doing in the
experiment is we're bringing in
a continuous stream of
electrons.
And here is my continuous
stream of electrons.
And I am only showing you two
atoms, but the same thing is
happening on a lot of atoms.
What it looks like is that
these electrons are coming in,
and then each one of these
atoms are kind of acting like a
point source reflecting the
electrons isotropically as a
wave.
That is that there is a wave
that's emanating out from each
one of the atoms.
And, of course,
as time goes on that propagates
out, and then another wave
front, another maximum emanates
out.
And, of course,
the distance between these two
maxima is the wavelength because
this is the maximum wave front,
here is another one.
With time it continues to
emanate out.
emanate out, as long as we are
throwing electrons at that
nickel crystal.
And it continues to emanate out
until it gets to the screen.
And then we see some bright,
dark, bright,
dark, bright spots.
It looks just like the two-slit
experiment.
And now, if we go to analyze
this.
Again, this is the same
drawing.
I just cleaned it up a little
bit.
If you look at this point right
here, what do you see?
Well, you see the maximum of a
wave scattered from atom one at
the same point in space as the
maximum of the wave scattered
from atom two.
Constructive interference.
Next point here,
again, two maxima,
the same points in space,
constructive interference.
Here two maxima,
the same point in space,
constructive interference.
Everywhere along that line we
have constructive interference.
And so if you project out to
the screen you're going to have
a bright spot there.
You're going to have electrons
being scattered right in that
angle.
And now we know,
we talked about last time what
the condition was for
constructive interference.
And the condition is the
difference in the distance
traveled by the two waves that
are constructively interfering.
Now I use the letter D instead
of R.
But the difference in the
distance has to be equal to an
integral multiple of the
wavelength.
And if you analyze this line
here of constructive
interference,
you would find it was N equals;
the difference in
the distance traveled was 1
lambda.
And over here,
you can see a row of
constructive interference.
And if you analyze this
constructive interference,
you would find the difference
in the distance traveled was 2
lambda.
This is our second-order
diffraction spot or second-order
interference feature.
And then, of course,
we had the zero-order
interference feature.
These electrons are behaving
like waves.
It's constructive and
destructive interference.
Now, what we are going to do is
we're going to analyze the
geometry of this setup a little
bit more.
We didn't do this for the
two-slit experiment with light.
We could have,
but we didn't.
We're going to do it here for
the electron scattering.
It's really the same thing.
And we're going to do it just
like Davidson and Germer did it.
Because from this analysis,
in particular from knowing what
the scattering angle is,
this is the quantity that
Davidson and Germer wanted to
measure, or were really
interested in,
this scattering angle which
turns out to be 50.7 degrees for
this first-order diffraction
beam.
We're going to use that
knowledge to calculate the
wavelength of the electron.
That's what we're aiming for,
here.
And we're going to do that
because of this known condition
for constructive interference,
that the difference in the
distance traveled by the two
waves that gives the
constructive interference has to
be an integral multiple of the
wavelength.
That's where we're headed.
Now, see this line from atom
number two to the screen?
I called it D2.
D2 is the length of that line.
It's the distance that the wave
has traveled from atom two to
the screen.
D1 is the distance that the
wave scattered from atom 1 has
traveled to the screen.
Now, I am going to draw a
perpendicular right here.
I am going to draw a
perpendicular from atom 1 to
this line D2.
Here is the right angle.
That is really nice because
look at what this leg of the
triangle is then.
It's D2 minus D1.
That's a quantity that's going
to be interesting to us.
Now, what you have to do is you
have to convince yourself that
this angle right in here,
in this triangle,
is equal to this scattering
angle theta.
If you're good at geometry you
can see that immediately,
or you might have to think
about it a little bit,
but it is equal to that.
Well, that's good because now
I've got a triangle right here.
And I know the length of one
side.
That is the distance,
the spacing between the two
nickel atoms in the crystal.
And I know what theta is
because that's what Davidson and
Germer measured.
Pretty good.
I can use this geometry to say
that sine theta is equal to the
length of the opposite side,
D2 minus D1,
over the hypotenuse A.
And now, if this is the
condition that has to obtain to
have constructive interference,
and then this expression comes
from the geometry of the problem
that I'm solving --
So, this is the theory,
this is the geometry of the
problem I'm solving.
Well, then N lambda has to be
equal to A sine theta.
And, therefore,
I can rearrange that to get
lambda, lambda is equal to A
sine theta divided by N.
And now I can use this
information here to calculate
what lambda is.
I know that the scattering
angle is 50.7 degrees.
I know what N is.
It's the first-order
diffraction feature because it
is the most intense spot that is
closest to the zero-order.
The zero-order is always going
to be normal to your sample,
normal to the crystal.
Therefore, I can plug some
numbers in there.
And I get for the wavelength
1.66x10^-10 meters.
This experiment says that if
you have electrons that are 54
eV in energy,
the wavelength of those
electrons is 1.66x10^-10 meters.
So, Davidson,
Germer and Thompson,
not only did they demonstrate
the interference phenomena of
particles, particles that had
mass.
But they were able to calculate
from that experiment the
wavelength, the corresponding
wavelength.
But now I just want to take a
moment, as an aside,
to tell you that this geometry
that I illustrated right here is
the identical geometry that is
used in X-ray diffraction.
X-ray diffraction is the
interference or the diffraction
of X-rays, photons.
This is electron diffraction.
But the geometries are the
same, the concepts are the same.
The reason I bring up X-ray
diffraction is because it is a
very important technique for you
in your future,
whether you're going to be
looking at materials to get the
structure of materials or
whether you're going to be doing
some kind of biological
chemistry.
Because X-ray diffraction is
used to get structures,
crystal structures,
particularly of proteins.
And the reason why you want to
know the structure of a protein
is because that structure does
give you some hints as to what
the function of the protein is.
And actually,
Professor Drennan,
who is going to lecture the
second half of the course,
that's her specialty,
is X-ray diffraction of crystal
proteins.
And I am sure she'll tell you
much more about that.
In X-ray diffraction,
what they do is they use those
results, not to get the
wavelength, but they use those
results to get this distance
here, A, the distance between
the atoms.
That's what I mean by getting
out the structure.
In X-ray diffraction,
they're coming in with an X-ray
beam.
And they know what the
wavelength is of their X-ray
beam, so they know what lambda
is.
And then they go and measure
what theta is,
the scattering angle.
And from those two quantities,
lambda and theta,
they figure out what A is,
the distance between the atoms
and therefore work out the
structure of the protein.
That is how X-ray diffraction
is actually used.
I think I can turn these back
on.
Let me just get this up a
little bit.
I'm not going to get the screen
all the way up because I still
want that number,
actually.
Not only did Davidson and
Germer, and Thompson,
demonstrate the interference
phenomena, but they also got out
of all of that a value for the
wavelength.
And that was very important.
And the reason why it was so
important is because a few years
before, 1924,
there was a prediction for what
the wavelength of particles
ought to be.
And that prediction was made by
this gentleman,
de Broglie.
De Broglie, in his Ph.D.
thesis, no less,
he made a prediction for what
the wavelength of particles
ought to be.
What he did is took the
relativistic equations of motion
of Einstein, the same identical
equations he knew of Einstein's
work, Ph.D.
thesis.
He realized that those
relativistic equations of motion
applied to matter as well as to
photons, to radiation.
And so he said,
that if you have,
of course, a photon which has a
wavelength lambda,
--
-- of course,
then that momentum of that
photon is p.
But since those equations also
apply to matter,
he then said,
well, if you have a particle
with momentum p,
that particle ought to have a
wavelength lambda.
He turned Einstein's
relativistic equations of motion
around.
Well, if radiation has a
wavelength lambda,
it ought to have momentum p.
This is what Einstein said.
De Broglie said,
well then, matter with a
momentum p better have a
wavelength lambda.
That's de Broglie's wavelength.
Isn't that amazing?
I think that's amazing.
Why didn't Einstein realize
this?
Or did Einstein realize that?
I don't know.
But let's see about this
prediction here.
What we know is that in the de
Broglie experiment that we had
electrons of 54 eV.
That is the kinetic energy,
that's one half m v squared.
You can write kinetic energy as
p squared over.
You can convince yourself of
this.
This is useful to know for
these kinds of problems,
p squared over 2m is the
kinetic energy.
Therefore, if this is the
energy, you can calculate the
momentum of those 54 eV
electrons.
So, the momentum is 4.0x10^-24
kilograms meters per second.
Now we can use de Broglie's
wavelength here,
that expression that he had
gotten out of Einstein's
relativistic equations of motion
to solve for lambda.
That is h, 6.626x10^-34 joule
seconds over the momentum.
And that gives 1.7x10^-10
meters.
The same as the experiment.
It predicted exactly what the
experimentalist measured for the
wavelength of the electron.
This was a real coup here for
de Broglie and for science.
What do we have?
We have Davidson,
Germer and George Thompson who
have demonstrated,
and in particular George
Thompson, who have demonstrated
that an electron has wave-like
behavior.
In contrast,
here is George Thompson's
father, J.
J.
Thompson, who has demonstrated
that an electron is a particle,
has mass.
And both the son and the father
are correct.
How often does that happen?
It's a really amazing story.
Now I am going to have to put
the lights off here.
I'm getting my lights confused.
Now we're at the point where we
can begin to understand the
structure of the atom.
Because it was this realization
of wave-like properties,
it was that realization of
those wave-like properties that
led this gentleman right here to
realize that maybe he had to
treat the electrons as a wave,
Mr.
Schrödinger.
It was that realization that
led Mr.
Schrödinger to write down the
Schrödinger equation,
the wave equation,
the equation of motion for
particles like an electron that
actually have a wavelength on
the order of their environment.
Actually, I just realized that
I skipped something in your
notes that I wanted to talk
about.
And I apologize for that.
We're going to get to the wave
equation in a moment,
it's very important.
But I did want to just talk
about, for a moment,
why if particles have waves or
have wake-like phenomena,
then why then hadn't this
wave-like phenomena been seen
before?
What this also should mean with
de Broglie is that you and I
have a wavelength because we've
got momentum,
we've got mass times velocity,
we also ought to have a
wavelength.
Pardon?
They take a while to go up,
yeah.
Let's consider the problem with
our wavelength here.
Well, let's talk about the
wavelength of a baseball.
We have a five ounce baseball
being pitched by Curt Shilling
at 90 mph.
And it's being pitched at a
very large nickel crystal.
Let's think of an experiment of
diffraction of baseballs from a
large crystal just like the
diffraction of the electrons
from that nickel crystal.
Well, let's calculate the
momentum of that baseball.
That momentum is m times v.
And 5 ounces,
90 miles per hour,
get all your units right,
is 5.6 kilogram meter per
second.
Then we're going to use de
Broglie's relationship right
here to calculate what the
wavelength is of that pitched
baseball.
And when we do that lambda is
equal to h over p.
He put in this p.
He put in h.
That comes out to be 1.2x10^-34
meters.
Pretty small.
But what do we know?
Well, we know the condition for
constructive interference,
D2 minus D1 has to be equal to
N times lambda,
has to be equal to A sine
theta.
Now let's calculate what the
angle theta ought to be for the
first-order diffraction feature
of baseballs from a nickel
crystal.
You have Curt Schilling
throwing these baseballs one
after another at this nickel
crystal, and you're trying to
see at what angle you are going
to see that first-order
diffraction feature.
Well, we can set this up so
that sine theta here is going to
be equal to N lambda over A.
So N is 1, lambda is 1.2x10^-34
meters, and then A is
2.15x10^-10 meters.
If you go and evaluate what
theta ought to be,
it's 3x10^-23 degrees.
That means if I have my huge
nickel crystal here and here's
the normal to the sample,
well, then that first-order
diffraction feature here is at
about 10^-23 degrees from the
normal.
Are you going to be able to
resolve that?
No.
You're not going to be able to
see the normal reflection.
And then no baseballs.
And then a very intense beam of
baseballs.
You're not going to be able to
resolve 10^-23 degrees.
You say, well,
okay, if that's the problem
then maybe I can help myself out
by changing this A here by
changing the distance of my
particles that are doing the
diffracting.
My two nickel atoms.
Let's change that distance.
Let's find some other crystal
such that I change that distance
to, let's see,
how about 7x10^-33 meters.
When I do that and I go and
calculate what theta ought to
be, that first-order diffraction
feature, well,
that comes out to about 1
degree.
If I was pitching baseballs at
the normal angle and I was
looking to see if I had a
maximum of baseballs 1 degree
from that normal angle,
could I resolve that?
Maybe.
Maybe you could get an
experiment like that and set it
up, but the problem is right
here.
The problem is in this A,
the distance between the atoms
in the nickel crystal that are
going to reflect these
baseballs.
This distance is 7x10^-33
meters.
How big is the diameter of a
nucleus?
What?
Negative 10?
How about another number.
Negative 11?
14.
10^-14 meters,
that's a good number to know.
What am I looking at here?
I'm looking at a distance
between the atoms of 10^-33
meters.
We're 20 orders of magnitude
smaller than the size of the
nucleus.
Do we have a crystal to
diffract baseballs off of where
the atoms are 10^-33 meters
apart?
Uh-uh, we don't.
And that's why wave-like
phenomena on macroscopic
particles has not been observed,
because our wavelengths,
your wavelengths,
my wavelengths,
baseball wavelengths,
these wavelengths are way too
small.
They're way too small because
the mass is way too large.
And so there is no way in the
macroscopic world that we're
going to see any effects,
any wave-like behavior from
macroscopic objects.
Our wavelengths are too small.
There is no way to see that
wave-like behavior.
You're going to need slits or
you're going to need atoms that
are about 10^-33 meters from
each other.
And that's just not practical.
For macroscopic objects,
for you and me,
our wavelengths don't mean
anything.
They are of no consequence in
the observation of what we see
around us.
However, they have lots of
consequences for particles such
as an electron whose environment
is on the scale of their
wavelength.
I am saying here,
in this case for the electron
where the wavelength is 10^-10
meters, is that is a wavelength
that is on the order of the size
of the electron's environment in
an atom.
That's 10^-10 meters.
In those cases,
when that wavelength is about
the size of the environment,
then the wave-like properties
matter.
They matter.
You see the interference
phenomena.
You see those effects of those
wave-like properties.
And it is just that realization
that led Schrödinger here,
who is now washed out,
to write down the wave equation
of motion.
And that's an equation of
motion for particles whose
wavelength is on the order of
the size of their environment.
And you have to use that
equation of motion to understand
how that electron,
so to speak,
moves.
You cannot use F equals ma.
And that is where we will pick
up next Wednesday.